we're asked to graph the circle which is
centered at 3 comma negative 2 and has a
radius of 5 units and i got this
exercise off of the khan academy graph a
circle according to its features
exercise it's a pretty neat little
widget here because what i can do is i
can take this
dot and i can move it around to redefine
the center of the circle so it's
centered at 3 comma negative 2. so x is
3 and y is negative 2. so that's its
center it has to have a radius of five
the way it's drawn right now it has a
radius of one the distance between the
center and the actual circle the the
points that define the circle right now
it's one i need to make this radius
equal to five so let's see if i take
that so now the radius is equal to two
three
four
and five
there you go centered at three comma
negative two radius of five notice to go
from the center to the actual circle
it's five no matter where you go
let's do one more of these
graph the circle which is centered at
negative 4 comma 1 and which has the
point 0 comma 4 on it
so once again let's drag the center so
it's going to be negative 4 x is
negative 4 y is 1 so that's the center
it has the point 0 comma 4 on it so x is
0 y is 4. so i have to drag
i have to increase the radius of the
circle let's see whoops nope i want to
make sure i don't change the center i
want to increase the radius of the
circle until it includes
this point right over here zero comma
four so i'm not there quite yet there
you go i am now including the point 0
comma 4. and if we're curious what the
radius is we could just go along the
x-axis x equals negative 4 is the
x-coordinate for the center and we see
that this point that this so this is
negative four comma one and we see that
one comma one is actually on the circle
so the distance here is you go four and
another one it's five so this has a
radius of five but either way we did
what they asked us to do